This is the story of
a very sick girl
and a set of events seen
two different ways.
Justina, just a very
special child.
I love you!
I love you too!
She was thriving.
About 10 years of age,
things changed.
She was in so much pain.
The hospital was alleging
the Pelletier family
was overmedicalizing
their daughter.
Overmedicalizing is getting
more medications or
procedures than they need.
Doctors are saying
Justina's parents
aren't making safe
decisions for her.
It just made no sense.
The juvenile court decided
to terminate the
parents' custody.
Linda and I never abused
any of our children.
Was Justina being abused?
I don't understand it.
Then something happens that changes everything.
This very ominous video
comes out from Anonymous.
And that's when all
hell broke loose.